[Musique]
si la journaliste elise lucet s'est fait
une spécialité de dévoiler des scandales
de notre société
il n'est pas étonnant que ses collègues
journalistes cherchent à l'autoroute
enquêter sur les coulisses du business
lucet car en quelques années sur france
2 la discrète journaliste est devenu une
figure de proue des scandales financiers
c'est dans cette optique que des
journalistes ont tenté de savoir combien
ils disent juste été rémunéré chaque
mois par le service public les citoyens
bien évidemment cet endroit où se poser
des questions et selon les résultats de
l'enquêté 18 ans empochera la coquette
somme de 25 mille euros par mois une
information que la journaliste est le
même à confirmer
ça dépend des mois mais oui ça tourne
autour de ça un salaire que certains
trouvent excessive pour une femme qui
dénonce les scandales financiers et qui
en profite au passage un salaire qui
correspond à son travail sur cash
investigations mais aussi envoyé spécial
alors c'est un jeu et fait un préambule
après je vous laisserai parler et c'est
un c'est une chose qui m'a toujours je
vais très sérieux deux minutes
agacé concernant les animateurs
producteurs qui ont la fâcheuse tendance
à balancer des sommes
on aura moi je suis salarié je gagne 5
mètres que c'était très bien je gagne
5000 ont arrêté des animateurs présure
de prendre les gens pour des cons et
données non parce qu'elle est votre
salaire mensuel mais le mouton vos
déclarations et ouverte entre le salaire
mensuel et l'éducation d'impôts on passe
de 1000 trouve que son salaire est là a
été à la hauteur de son expérience 30
ans de journalisme beaucoup de succès on
parle de cash investigations ont parlé
des banderilles spéciales et le
surréalisme et pas que elle a aussi
rédactrice en chef et la double des
responsabilités et considérait
d'ailleurs par le dernier sondage de
l'ifop comme la journaliste la plus
influente du plat aujourd'hui donc je
crois que c'est totalement mérité par
rapport à ce qu'elle touche à lille
depuis 1988 à un moment donné à la halle
exactement le même salaire qu'un
directeur de patrimoine à des halles à
un salaire convenable pour ça qu'ils
enseignent la plus sur moi je pense que
c'est vraiment son salaire c'est à elle
de caches
je vais tout vous expliquer quand vous
êtes producteur de l'émission moi je
prends d'une émission r on donne un
million d'euros je me donne un salaire
de 1200 francs à 2100 euros
le la marge c'est pour moi le vrai sujet
c'est que elle est productrice
voilà donc on sait très bien que là elle
doit pas être très à l'aise déjà on
avait dans cette somme parce que le thon
élise lucet fait quand même elle y va
elle agresse les gens à y va fort est ce
que il ne touche pas beaucoup plus on
tombe bien sûr crif là il vrai sujet
c'est moi je vous après en france et
vous communiquez sur l'argent c'est très
mauvais c'est à ce moment-là 57 en f1
mais il faut savoir c'est que
malheureusement c'est un marronnier en
cette polémique autour d'élise lucet
depuis 2000 18 ans la boîte quasiment
religieusement à la même période de
l'année mais il ya répondu très vite
c'est une fuite d'un de ses collègues
d'ailleurs à l'époque voir les stars
donc des gens qui n'y mette étanche
séparant par folie des fluides par des
biens pour élise lucet donc cette
fameuse somme de 25000 euros remonte à
2018 donc peut-être qu évidemment
aujourd'hui c'est pas actuelle mais elle
a tout de suite assumer et je pense
qu'effectivement c'est mérité pour mr
servent à la réglisse et week end peur
les 25000 euros moi ça me choque pas
parce qu'elle a du talent et elle est à
la tête des missions qui marche mais
pour autant et les us et qui enquêtent
tout le temps sur les conditions de
travail de certaines entreprises
devraient peut-être se concentrer sur
une enquête sur la précarité qui règne
sur le service public parce qu'à des
contrats qui sont précaires et
j'aimerais savoir sur une échelle de 1 à
10 ou de 1 à 20 à combien s'élève le
salaire du plus petit collaborateurs qui
travaillent avec elle
db non bah si ça va c'est là ab non oui
là franchement c'est un au débat il faut
pas oublier qu aussi un salaire est fixé
en fonction de ce que la personne
rapporte aucun moment donné je voudrais
aussi savoir combien l'émission rapporte
au service mais bien sûr la production
formée qui a des dizaines et pour que
les procurer moi j'ai gagné et donnez
nous communiquez pas votre salaire c'est
que désormais
il faut avoir fait payer dix ans je le
paye encore